لا يستطيعون الجلوس ان لم يكن هناك وسيله
تدفئه تتوسط المكان مدفاه كهرباء تضاء
بشعله واحده ووجودها يقتصر على تخفيف حده
البرد فقط ومع تعدد وتوفري وسائل التدفئه
في الاردن الا ان حال ثائر كغيره من
الاردنيين دفعهم لاختيار اقلها مراره خاصه
مع ارتفاع اسعار الكاذي مؤخرا والسولار
الذي لم يكن ضمن الخيارات اصلا اضافه لسوء
الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
صعوبه اكثر من السنه اللي قبليها بالنسبه
للتدفئه بقدونس
فالكهرباء الكهرباء
ومحوله لفصل الشتاء سجلت المشتقات النفطيه
نسبه الارتفاع الاعلى باسعارها بتاريخ
الاردن شكوى المواطن تتكرر في كل عامه في
حين تتجه الحكومه لرفع اسعار المشتقات
النفطيه في بلد مستورد لها من جهه ويواجه
ازمات نقتصاديه جديده من جهه اخرى
فقط في المشتقات المدعومه مثل الغاز بينما
للسولار
والكاز الاسعار مرتفعه وقد لا يستطيع
المواطن استخدامها في التدفئه فبالتالي
معتقد بانه هذا الشتاء سيكون صعب جدا في
على الاردنيين في الفتره الحاليه والله
نلجا للكهرباء بتكون اوفر شويه طبعا كنا
للعام يعني نستهلك الديزل فالسنه هاي
الديزل صراحه كان غالي كثير الايام هاي
ارتفاع واسعار الكهرباء حقيقه يلمسها
المواطن الا انها باتت الحل الانسبه ربما
امام المواطنين مقارنه بارتفاع المشتقات
النفطيه غير المدعومه حكوميه مشهد يتكرر
في كل الشتاء لكنه قد يكون الاصعب هذه
المره على مواطن انهكه مسلسل ارتفاع
الاسعار الذي يطال معظم احتياجاته سوها
جميل العربيه عمان